hmm okay so I'm here but am I really me
or I'm about to burst into a sea of
badly aged CGI
[Applause]
[Music]
Doctor Who overdue review two-parter
time and that means that we have arrived
at the rebel flesh and the almost people
I've always kind of contended that this
is an underrated story because I feel
like it should be talked about more
often than it is it's not amazing I
wouldn't put it like in the top tier or
anything but for what it is aiming to be
and do it does it really really well and
I kind of wish it got cited more as like
a really strong example of the
integration of themes and the execution
of a two part or a pacing one over two
episodes with a limited cast in limited
setting it like it's just really well
put together and I feel like it doesn't
get a lot of credit for that
so this is the one where the doctor
takes Amy and Rory to a castle where
they are mining acid for who knows they
may have said but honestly it doesn't
matter there's acid that's all that
matters and because this stuff is so
dangerous to work with the people
basically have flesh avatars they call
them their gangers there is a somewhat
organic they're not entirely sure they
know that it works a compound called the
flesh that they can basically tap into
and then control which allows them to
stay in a safe space while their gang er
goes out and does things in dangerous
spots and if it falls into acid and
melts away no harm no foul it's just a
lump of matter being controlled by
somebody and that person is perfectly
fine everything's good yeah it's not
because the doctor is very quick to
notice um the flesh is growing it's
alive it is a living thing it gets
brushed off well yeah it's is no more
sentient than moss well and soon we have
the somewhat predictable and what you
would expect given that initial set up
issue of the gangers start up and start
walking around on their own without
needing the
original people to be plugged into them
so now we have a gangers versus humans
scenario where people are literally
faced with their literal selves and are
in conflict and the doctor trying to
deal with all that it seems really good
it's not breaking a ton of new ground it
is ultimately a base under siege style
story it has very limited locations and
the cast is is very small the few bits
of CGI don't look great they're not
badly designed which can sometimes be
the issue when you get into things like
like the Lazarus experiment but that you
can very much tell this is on a TV
budget so I mean there's all that going
on but it just does what it's doing
really well because this type of story
gets told in science fiction rather
often but usually it's something that we
would be dealing with clones or or
robots and doing either one of those
kind of tips the argument of are these
people do they deserve rights harder in
one direction or the other by its nature
not to say that you know the resolution
can't land wherever the writer wants it
to but when you're doing robots becoming
sentient there's a certain disconnect
for an audience because well that are
you saying I should be nicer to the
coffee maker in my kitchen because
they're inherently less human whereas if
you're dealing with clones you know an
actual true literal clone then well yeah
you made a human being that yeah that's
a person and the gangers actually fall
nicely in between while still tackling a
lot of the same themes and questions
that those kinds of stories in sci-fi
settings tend to ask because the gangers
have all of the memories and the
experiences of the people who have who
had been plugged into them and created
them as their avatars in their head as
far as they are concerned that was their
life yet at the same time they are still
in some ways physically distinct you can
differentiate you can tell who is I mean
they don't necessarily have a ton of
ways to do it in the situation they're
in in the story but there are ways to do
it
so you have something that
all rationale of what they are
physically composed of is not a person
and is certainly not the person they
look like yet they are an exact copy and
I love the way that that is played here
the way that characters especially
interact with each other because yes we
get a point where the gangers decide
that they need to take out the humans
but it's not because the gangers are
inherently evil and they were just
pretending to manipulate know they're
making the decision that the human
versions of them are also making to some
degree and everything tracks really well
especially with the way some characters
are really unnerved by the fact that
they are looking at something that looks
like them but it isn't it and other
characters kind of soften kind of like
find value or find some connection in
that I love that there is a diversity of
reactions and responses and thought
processes between the different
characters and we've also got the mirror
image of those between the humans and
the gangers I like that of course
inevitably we end up with a gang or
doctor and I really do enjoy those
interactions of the doctor and I'm gonna
call him John Smith because that's what
he calls himself except that wasn't
actually the gang or that was the doctor
cuz he played a little who could quick
switch whatever but moving on so I
really enjoyed the two of them and it's
actually if you stop and think about
it's kind of a really cool idea because
we've had the issue before with things
like the doctor Donna that humans cannot
contain everything that is a Time Lord
and signed them apparently though the
flesh can it's a little wonky when John
Smith first forms and he's trying to
comprehend all these years and these
multiple lives and everything but after
a little while he's fine like some think
about that the flesh can actually
process and deal with a Time Lord that's
kind of cool it doesn't really get
remarked Tom but that struck me this
time I'm like oh that's nifty and I like
how the doctor is instantly on the same
wavelength as John Smith right down to
their mess
with Amy and I watching at this time in
knowing that that twist was coming not
that it's especially hard to spot that's
I mean that's one thing that I'll say
like maybe slight we pretty much every
twist of oh the person who you thought
was a human was a gang or vice versa
though they're all pretty easy to spot
early on but the plot is built in such a
way that you being surprised by that
doesn't make or break the story if you
catch on to it soon too early maybe you
get annoyed that the characters haven't
but the story doesn't pivot and depend
on you being surprised by these twists
so even though most of these if not all
of them you can spot and call and are
maybe telegraphed a little more than
they need to be that doesn't break the
narrative or the story at least I don't
think it does but I the I did wonder
going back and watching again knowing
that the doctor basically switched with
his ganger to see what Amy didn't how
she reacted and responded to that I
wondered is this going to feel like it
was somebody he needed to do or is this
kind of feel like a twist for the sake
of a twist but it did need to happen not
necessarily logistically I'm not the
logistical reason that the doctor gives
for doing that and pulling that off
pulling that particular move is a little
vague and a little shaky but it's
massively important fanatically it is
important to the understanding of where
things land with the flesh that they are
the audience is supposed to be on their
side and believe that yes they need to
be recognized as people and the fact
that they were being cranked out and
then thrown away is wrong really kind of
needs Amy to go through the experience
that she goes through of distrusting the
one she believes is the ganger being so
certain and then having that flip
revealed on her and like getting teared
up at realizing the ganger one is going
to die and feeling probably about as
close as she felt in terms of the pain
of having seen the doctor die back in
the Impossible Astronaut so seeing her
journey is incredibly important to
matically so it absolutely did need to
happen if you're someone who doesn't
think theming
Trump logistics then maybe you still
take issue with it at the end of the day
as long as it doesn't completely fail to
make any kind of sense
I think strong Femi is slightly more
important then than just the logistical
everything fits together sort of thing
and I think this forms the balance of
that quite quite well all the
performances are good this does what I
like a two-parter to do we have an
established core group of of new
characters and we spend time with them
and get to know them that when two
parters do that properly is what a big
part of what I love about two partners
it's one of the things I love about
things like the impossible planet and
the Satan pitch is you really get to
know these people and they feel like
more than just guest stars and that is
the case here the performances are all
great and I'm not gonna lie I choked up
a little bit with the father because one
of the people who's there he's a dad and
it's his son's fifth birthday and the
ganger feels that exact same affection
and the real one dies and the ganger is
now effectively his father now I
remember back when it first aired I
wondered is that a little cheap because
they're they're avoiding the difficult
question of if they both live does the
gang or have any parental right I mean
legally probably not but like have any
moral right to ask to see what is as far
as he's concerned his son and they kind
of dodged that by having the real one
die except that while that is kind of
the case I still like it because of the
performance from him is really really
great and despite the fact that the
child actor when we get a hollow call
the child actor is not good like he's
easy he's a five easy five year-old boy
he's a child actor he's as awkward and
bad as child actors tend to be at that
age but the guy the father especially as
the gayer sells it not just the love but
selling the realization that he now has
a responsibility to this boy because his
real father is gone so it's not just
that he has love for this boy he has a
responsibility this means something and
it's all
the face all the acting's in the face
and I did choke up it was so good it
overrode the fact that this kid on the
Holocaust
not good then so like the kid didn't jug
me up at all the dad did though yeah a
little bit and I just feel like this is
really well put together it's really
well constructed for the themes that
it's dealing with for the type of the
for the way it's chosen to format the
story in terms of like we got to get off
the base on there's trouble uh which
again is not a typical Ford are true but
it's just well executed on pretty much
every level the only major criticism I
had really was the CGI and like they did
the best that they could there's a few
things that maybe aren't quite as tight
as they could be but overall this is a
really complete package and the other
thing I want to give this thing credit
for is the way in which it ties into the
overarching story that's going on this
series so I have commented in the past
about my extreme distaste for what I
have termed the mystery box story arcs
which means something that we either
keep seeing or keep hearing mentioned
that doesn't get explained until series
finale now series 6 is already a little
bit weird cuz they basically have a mid
series finale but anyway examples before
like bad wolf Torchwood vote Saxon the
the planets moving and you know rows
showing up in the series four series
five had the cracks and in time and I
dislike that format in the first place
but one of the main things I really
don't like about it is the reminders of
who this thing they just don't get
integrated into the stories they just
show up like as a reminder who thing now
series six does have that it has that in
the form of you know the eyepatch
Willman so it does have a mystery box
thing going on but one of the issues
that I tend to have with that is the
failure to integrate so oftentimes the
things that quote-unquote especially
under Moffitt it actually happens under
Moffat more than habit under Davies but
things that move the series arc forward
are very detachable from the episodes in
which they happen I think my best
example of that
is the Silurian two-parter from series 5
because at the end of that Rory dies and
is swallowed up by the time prac now
that's actually really important this is
a big deal this matters but it has
almost nothing to do with the story
that's going on the fact that he was
killed and sucked into the that could
have been tacked on to literally any
story it didn't have to happen here
there's no reason for it to have any air
this just happened to be the episode
where they did it it's very disconnected
and that frustrates me here the thing
that moves the overall series thing
forward is the revelation that Amy is a
ganger and real Amy somewhere else
captured is pregnant and about to give
birth now these things have been hinted
out up to this point and the hints being
dropped have been very much what I've
been saying they're just in there and
actually you you're you'd be forgiven
forgetting what episodes they even
happen in and how because they're so
completely detached here they take a
story as far as the story being told you
know of the of the gangers them becoming
sentient the conflict and then the
gangers making the argument for their
rights that story is a completely
self-contained story and yet it feeds
directly into what is revealed about Amy
because the flesh the doctor had to
learn about the flesh in order to figure
out what was going on with this version
of Amy he knew something was wrong but
he needed to learn more and that's how
we got into this situation so it builds
directly off it and then thrusts us into
the series story and the next episode
this is one of the best integrations of
what is an otherwise stand-alone story
into the overall series arc because
usually they're super detached and that
is not the case here and I wanted to
shout that out because that is something
that nine times out of ten on Doctor Who
I don't feel is done especially well and
tends to bug me so yeah
rebel flesh and the almost people I
think it is quite good well what do you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something on the comments let's
talk about it stuff to do as well
patreon and liking and subscribing and
sharing all of which are very helpful
and greatly greatly appreciated I hope
everyone's having a great holiday season
as we get towards the end of the year
and you know like I said tons of stuff
down there for you to click on go places
do things but you don't have to because
at the end of the day folks you are the
council
I'm just running the meetings until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]